Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's March 9, 2023.
We're in ActInf GuestStream number 38.1
here with Max Berg.
Thank you, Max, for joining.
This is going to be great.
Really looking forward to your
presentation and discussion.
So appreciation again for joining and
looking forward to what you'll share with
us today.
Max: Yes, thank you, Daniel, for having
me. As I was introduced,
my name is Max Berg.
I come from the University of Marburg and
I'm a clinical psychologist.
I want to do a little bit of impression
management first.
So Marburg is next to Frankfurt, in case
you don't know.
It's a small or medium city in Germany.
And regarding me, I'm interested in the
intersection of clinical psychology,
neuroscience and philosophy.
That doesn't mean that I'm an expert in
all of these fields.
Of course, I have a lot of knowledge in
clinical psychology, I would say, and the
rest is more of my hobbies.
And so it's important that you keep in
mind to expect a clinical perspective
today.
I'm not an expert on Bayesian mathematics
or anything like that.
I know a little bit about it and I've
read books about it and try to keep
myself updated.
But it's not my expertise.
My expertise is clinical psychology.
And what I want to present today is like
a paper about depressive rumination.
But we will see that it's not important
that it's depressive rumination.
And rumination is a much broader
construct here and we want to rephrase,
like depressive rumination from active
inference lab perspective.
And this is what we want to talk about
today.
I want to start with a little quote.
And it's romantic is the coin of my
realm.
Interiority breeds interiority.
And we will see that this might be
literary true.
And this is why I think it's a good quote
to start with.
So what is rumination?
It is defined by the APA as obsessional
thinking involving excessive repetitive
thoughts or themes that interfere with
other forms of mental activity.
It is a common feature of OCD and
generalized anxiety disorder.
I actually don't know why these two
disorders were chosen first, but well,
here we go.
I just quoted them here.
I would add a major depression to the
list, and at least in my mind, major
depression is the prototype disorder for
rumination.
But sure, OCD and generalized anxiety
disorder also has a lot of rumination
going on.
And here you can see a first really
important point, namely that Rumination
is a transdiagnostic marker.
Right.
It's important for multiple psychiatric
conditions.
And yeah, as such, it's an important
transdiagnostic risk factor and it can
predict, actually depression scores and
subsequent measurement time points.
And this is what makes it interesting.
There was like a grant, a small grant
proposal by, I believe, the Wellcome
Trust in the UK where they gave grants
for writing systematic reviews about
transdiagnostic topics in mental health.
And unsurprisingly rumination is one of
the topics where they gave or where they
wanted to have systematic reviews for
which they can see that it's an important
topic where people really believe that it
has some utility, clinical utility.
And unfortunately it is also the case
that it's associated with worse treatment
response for psychotherapy and also for
medication treatment.
Yeah, and let's make it more complicated,
shall we?
The rumination is sometimes used
interchangeably with the concept of
repetitive negative thinking.
And sometimes repetitive negative
thinking means rumination and various
varying.
But we will use the definition of
rumination in its broader sense today.
So when I talk about rumination I also
mean varying some of the time.
I just wanted to make this clear at the
beginning so I use it in the older
broader sense.
So to say yes.
So why would we need a new concept for
rumination?
Well, reinforcement learning, I would say
reinforce struggles to explain the
constant continuation of ruminative
thinking.
To make it short, why should you continue
with doing something that is not giving
you like pleasure or any good feelings in
the short or the long run?
Why is something continued despite not
promoting action and also leading to
depressed mood?
This is a question at hand.
It's not an easy question to answer, I
would say.
And this is why we would say that we have
to not only take exploitation learning
into account but also take exploration
learning or surprise reducing learning or
free energy minimization into account,
however you want to call it.
The important part is you have to take
into account that not all learning is
done in the sense of like reinforcement
learning but there's also learning that
we do to know more about the world.
And if this goes wrong, rumination can
occur and this is how we want to rephrase
it today.
Yes.
So this is the roadmap for today.
We want to reconceptualize Rumination as
an extreme case of failed mental problem
solving.
We want to present a model of Rumination
using active inference terminology.
So this will be a conceptual model.
We don't have the mathematics to back it
up at the moment.
I will talk about this limitation at the
end again and we will also discuss
neurobiological correlates shortly to
then continue to point towards treatment
implications of the model.
So the next part is like I want to talk a
little bit about problem solving and
mental problem solving.
And I've had a classic quote by Richard
Dawkins that I really find interesting in
this context.
It says survival machines that can
simulate the future are one step ahead of
survival machines who can only learn on
the basis of overt trial and error.
The trouble with over trial is that it
takes time and energy.
The trouble with overt error is that it's
often fatal.
Simulation is both safer and faster.
And I think this is really interesting
and we can talk about also like this
evolutionary perspective later.
I have really broke it down into simple
terms first, okay, so when I want to
solve problems using my mind, what do I
need to do?
Well, at first, I need to think about
what to do next, what do I want to think
about, so to say.
And we have called this step candidate
sampling.
So it's meter policy, basically.
So what do I even want to think about
before thinking about what are important
tasks of today, for example?
And then the next step is policy
evaluation.
Or if I think about that, what are the
expected results?
If I tell them about this concept, will
they understand my talk today, for
example?
And then let's say, yes, I hope that this
is the case.
Then we have to do another step and do
the actual problem solving.
Okay, now I'm convinced that this might
be the right way, but how to do it, how
to actually solve the problems, which are
the steps necessary?
And these three steps we will consider
over and over again today.
And whereas in the paper, neat little
example that happens to me a lot.
That's one of the reasons I recharge it
today.
Imagine you lost your key.
And now what we typically do is at first
we check the usual places, oh, have I put
it there?
No, have maybe put it there.
And after a while, if this doesn't work,
my policy changes typically.
And I think, okay, where did I see my key
the last time that I saw it?
And trace it back, and maybe this works
and I find my key back.
And a few days after, I have the same
problem again because I already lost my
key again.
And what I may do after a few instances
of this behavior is like, okay, I need to
change something fundamentally in order
to get my key back faster.
And so in Beijing, learning terms at the
beginning, my expected prediction error
minimization is just search the usual
places.
It might work.
Okay, after a while, the mental policy,
okay, why do I keep losing the key?
And how do I solve this problem?
Might lead to a higher expected free
energy minimization or prediction error
reducing properties.
And this is why I switched the policy,
right after a while.
So this meter policy step decides how to
go or how to go about a given problem, in
this case, how to find my key.
Good.
This is really important.
We cannot search the intractably large
probability distribution for this step.
It's not possible to remember all
instances where I lost my key and to
compare, like, promising strategies based
on the whole distribution.
I'm not able to do this.
No machine, no living being.
We have to find fitting samples, so to
say.
And fitting means it's usually based on
heuristics.
What did I do the last time when the key
was gone?
How can I find it?
This will become important later, because
these Heuristics can run into problems.
They help us, like, make computationally
intractable problems solvable.
But these heuristics have also their
downsides as we want to discuss.
Okay, then, step two.
Now, policies are then selected if they
provide a trade off between pragmatic and
epistemic value and pragmatic is okay, I
have a good chance of finding my key back
to stay on the example.
And epistemic is I learn also something
about finding keys or understand the
world better.
And this is also important.
Whenever I choose a specific policy, high
opportunity costs may arise.
What I mean with that is when I pursue a
searching process, for example, for
finding my key, I cannot continue
preparing my talk or something like
that.
So every decision I make has necessary
costs because I cannot pursue other goals
at the same time and this is also
becoming going to become important.
So in order to be chosen by an organism,
each chosen policy has to outweigh the
resulting opportunity cost.
Otherwise it's not adaptive, right?
Okay.
And now the last step, the mental problem
solving.
Good.
I now decided for one strategy of finding
my key and now I have to actually pull it
off.
So where to search, what to do next,
which sequences of movements do I have to
perform and how to go about it best and
typically in different strands of
literature, not just an active
inference.
I need to perform something that is
called research.
You know this from chess playing
typically or from chess computers.
They do it a lot better than we do, but
they look okay.
If I do this move and he does this move,
then I can do this move and in all moves
that follow it, I have a good position.
And it's again not possible to search the
whole tree because the more branches, the
more branches are daughter branches of
these branches again.
So the tree grows exponentially.
So I need to have a strategy of not
searching through all the branches.
It's called a pruning strategy.
In the case of Bayesian learning, it's
often occam's window, meaning that
branches are not searched through if they
don't promise a prediction error
minimization that is sufficient to pursue
searching them.
This can also lead into problems because
if a branch at first doesn't provide
enough prediction error and minimization,
it will not be searched through despite
the fact that it could have some
prediction error minimization further
down the road, so to say.
But we have to prune again because it's
not possible to search the whole
distribution.
Okay, so with these three steps in mind,
we can have the following model.
So we have the candidate sampling how to
go about the loss key, so to say, policy
evaluation.
If I do the strategy, do I have a good
chance of finding the key and learning
something about the world and mental
problem, how to actually pull this
strategy off.
And I want to say one really important
thing and this is an increase in mental
problem solving is a normal process in a
lot of situations, right?
So for example, if I lose a person, that
is really important for me, it's normal
that my general model decreases.
Like a lot of my strategies for getting
social supports don't work anymore
because the person is gone.
And so in invasion terminology,
prediction errors increase after such an
event and this is a normal process.
And if, like, my general model declines,
this was linked in the active inference
literature to bad mood or to feelings of
sadness, for example.
And in such cases, typically you think
more about fundamental things in your
life, everybody knows it and has
experienced it.
If you don't feel well, you tend to think
more and to try to get into a better
situation again and hopefully what
happens then is okay.
For example, I lost someone, my social
support system is breaking together or
breaking apart, falling apart.
So after a while, I search for people
that I like and that can form a new bond
with.
And hopefully, after a while, my
prediction errors become smaller again.
But therefore, I need to take action.
I need to think about what to do with my
lies, how to get to know new people in
this example, to reduce my prediction
errors in this case, regarding social
support.
And then I have to pull it up, I have to
go to certain places to meet people and
hopefully after a while of sadness and
difficult times, my general model fit
increases again.
But this is not always the case, as we
now want to discuss next.
So I have yet another quote.
You will get to use two quotes today,
sorry.
The next quote is about rumination and it
says shut up, she tells her monkey mind
please shut up, you picker of knits,
presser of bruises, counter of losses,
fear of failures, collector of
grievances, future and past and now we
want to discuss what happens when this
doesn't work.
So it can happen that despite trying,
agents and organisms don't find good
approximations for important problems in
their life, right?
And if this is the case, the prediction
errors regarding these problems stay high
because surprising doesn't get resolved.
And despite trying, the organism tries
over and over again.
Prediction errors say hi, surprising
doesn't get resolved and the prediction
error doesn't reduce again and the
problem stays.
And what we now want to do is discuss
reasons for why this happens in
depressive rumination.
And at first we have to say okay, typical
rumination problems have high complexity
with uncertainties at many hierarchical
levels.
If you think about problems, for example,
like why is the world such a cruel
place?
For example, this could be a nice
rumination problem.
You would have to gather a lot of
evidence from different strains.
It's really hard to actually disprove
such a claim or to prove such a claim or
even to say what it means.
And this is why there might be no
efficient solution for such a question.
It's not like navigating a maze or
something like that, but it's much more
complicated.
And in addition, sometimes like we human
beings have very high precision demands
for solutions.
For example, after I may have survived a
traumatic event, I might be really
reluctant to go to similar looking places
again.
And I have to be really sure that the new
place where I don't want to go is really
different from the place where something
bad happened to me.
And if I'm not sure and sure means really
sure, high precision, I won't go there.
And these complexity demands can also
make an efficient approximation to a
problem improbable.
And this might be one reason why problem
solving isn't functioning in the case of
Depressive Rumination.
Another reason might be over pruning and
missing action policies.
So as I said beforehand, like pruning in
order to action properly, or let's say
this way, pruning is a good strategy when
the parts of the surge tree that I
remove, so to say, don't yield.
Like at the beginning, small losses and
at the end large gains.
Because if it's like that, the tree
branch might be pruned away despite
actually helping the organism to reduce
surprisal.
But the organism will never find out
because it gets pruned away.
And the next thing is also, action
policies can only be thought through if
an agent knows about them.
We know about a lot of depression
patients with a lot of childhood
adversities that actually don't know a
lot of strategies for navigating social
environments.
It's not their fault, it's a consequence
of childhood adversities.
But nevertheless, this is a problem.
If I don't know the solution for a social
problem, I cannot approximate a solution
because action policies are missing.
And the next problem might be that after
many failed attempts of problem solving,
I might not even have a reason to engage
in deeper instrumental learning.
What I mean with that?
I go back one slide.
After a while I have an idea.
Okay, why is my life becoming so shitty?
It is because I don't engage with other
people anymore.
I just lie in my bed and feel sad.
Okay?
And now normally there would be a step
where I think about how to engage with
other people again.
But if I have, for example, missing
action policies, really bad mood and not
a lot of strategies, I might think this
through shortly and think, well, I can
try, but they won't like me anyway.
So instead of deep mental problem
solving, I jump back to step one, which
is why do I have so many problems with
other people?
And there you can see illuminated circle
is forming and no deeper engagement is
possible anymore.
And if this happens, my prediction errors
stay large and more candidate sampling
occurs.
Okay, I cannot solve this by meeting
other people, but maybe I can do it on my
own.
No I feel so sad and lonely.
You see where this is going.
I do not engage anymore in deeper problem
solving, but instead thinking through a
lot of policy candidates and none of them
is like giving me confidence that I can
solve my problems.
So I stay at the same meter policy
selection step, so to say.
And in consequence I have less
instrumental thinking and less
instrumental learning.
And this also has consequences.
For example, the pragmatic value of
policies are estimated to be low due to
low model fit.
And this even becomes worse over time.
So if I think I cannot do it, I will not
train it.
If I do not train it, I become even worse
at doing it.
And so it becomes more and more
improbable that I try because my action
policies become more and more under
trained.
And this is another really important
problem.
And the next problem is the opportunity
cost because I ruminate a lot.
So now we are at a meter level, I don't
do much else and because I don't do much
else, my model fit further declines.
And yes, the rest we talked about on the
last slide.
So Ruminated states may be learned as the
agent's default response for,
quoteunquote, dealing with problems after
a while.
And now we have a wishes cycle here.
And the next thing that I want to discuss
is how neurobiology might play a role
here.
And I have had a little joke of Phil
Colette ripped off for my slides here and
quotation by Karl Friston that says an
agent does not have a model of its world,
it is a model.
In other words, the form, structure and
states of our embodied brains do not
contain a model of the sensoriums.
They are that model.
And on the right you can see like a Yale
School of Management guy that actually
really embodies this principle as he's
clearly showing on his backpack.
Okay, jokes aside, what was supposed to
be said?
The Default Mode network is going to be
important for our discussion here.
The Default Mode network is a largescale
network with mediofrontal, temporal and
pariatal regions in the brain.
It's important for introspection,
selfreferential thinking and
autobiographical recall.
So in short, it's important for
everything mental, problem solving and
Rumination related or a lot of these
things.
And this is why it's unsurprisingly going
to play a role here.
And to be more precise, the frontal
courtesies seem to be the main driver of
memory recall in the Default Mode
network.
So if the Default Mode network tries now
I'm intermorphalizing it to recall a
memory.
So where do I find the key?
For example, it uses the frontal regions
to be the main driver of this process.
And it is the case that meter studies
found a stronger coupling and a
hyperactivation in Default Mode network
structures to be correlated with
Ruminations.
And there are actually two meter analysis
that found this and it is also suggested
that a coupling with sub Lagrangian
cortex might contribute to the negatively
agent nature of rumination MdD.
So we know, okay, Dmn is important for
problem solving and for rumination and
it's also found meta analytically that it
indeed plays a role for rumination or at
least it's correlated.
And in addition, meter studies also found
evidence for a reduced frontier periodic
control network within network
connectivity in major depression.
And this is also interesting because as
we discussed, our idea is basically that
rumination means I get stuck in abstract
thinking and don't use my instrumental
learning capabilities as much.
And so it makes sense that in MdD we find
reduced control network or front of
periodical control network activity.
Note by the way that this part of the
evidence line is more indirect than the
part before, right, I don't want to gloss
over this.
So while we have here a direct
correlation with Rumination, in the case
of the default mode network here it's
more Mvd in general.
This is why we also wrote it much more
careful in the paper because it's a more
indirect line and I don't want to gloss
over that.
And it is further more known that a
connection between control networks and
default mode networks seem to be
reduced.
And interestingly these two networks have
to connect in order to solve complicated
problems.
They actually study about that and these
studies suggest that if the problem gets
harder for an individual, it uses more of
the default mode network to do the meter
thinking and then the control networks to
do the problem solving and the interplay
between the two is really important.
Okay, so in conclusion, what we think
could be the case is that the default
network is hyperactive and hyper
connected.
Because it does policy candidate over
sampling that we talked about before and
the reduced mental problem solving.
Or instrumental learning due to the
policy over sampling is reflected by the
reduced resting state activation and the
hyperconnectivity of the control networks
and also of integration hubs like the
insula.
Okay, then a short citation, it will be
the last one and it's existentialist
model and it says simply existence
precedes essence.
And it wants us to say okay, in the first
instance we are beings that get thrown
into the world, but we have to do
something with our lives in order to
flourish and give ourselves reasons to
live and to succeed.
And I want to talk a little bit about how
can we get out of ruminative loops and
what might be old idea and new dean.
At first I want to say there's good
evidence for the effectiveness of
existing psychotherapeutic treatment
regarding depression in general and it's
also regarding rumination.
So we also have like meta analysis
specifically analyzing rumination.
However, we have substantial non
responder rates for psychotherapy and
also for current medication approaches.
We have a high chance for relapse after
depression is gone, it will oftentimes
reoccur in the life of patients,
unfortunately.
And we also have substantial therapy
dropouts so patients actually leaving
therapy.
So it's really easy to say that
psychological and pharmacological
treatment needs improvement.
So they are effective but they don't help
everyone and there's a lot of room for
improvement here.
And there are multiple ideas that we
briefly discussed in the paper and the
first is like a simple idea but could be
quite effective and has also meta
analytical evidence that it helps.
And this is like reduce memory
interference and rumination by physical
exercise in the everyday lives of
patients.
So doing more like especially endurance
exercises actually helps reducing
rumination even when compared to active
treatment like CBT.
So maybe depressing patients don't only
need therapy to be paid for but also to
have a personal trainer that might be
paid for.
And I only say this half jokingly, this
could improve the life of a lot of
people.
And another idea is more medical
stylocybin or ketomine was shown in
studies to increase the sampling entropy
of the brain and this could also be an
interesting prospect because we've
learned that the samples are getting
repeated over and over again.
But if we could have an idea for how to
increase the variance of samples drawn
then probability that one sample is
actually a good idea for thinking through
increases.
However, I have to say cautionary notes,
especially with psychedelic drugs because
it is a promising pharmacological avenue
probably, but at the moment we have
really small sample sizes.
It's hard to blind for these drugs
between groups.
I mean, you know, when you are tripping
it's quite easy to know.
So this makes RCTs difficult and we know
from a lot of questionable research
practices from this line of research,
unfortunately.
I don't want to say that everybody in
these fields are doing bad science, it's
not what I want to say but I know from a
few cases where preregistered protocols
don't fit the results that were presented
and stuff like this.
And if you combine all this it's actually
quite hard to say whether these work
really well.
So what we would need is really larger
study, not these small brain imaging
studies with 20 subjects, more like 200
subjects would be a beginning and we need
the researchers to actually stick to
predefined interpretations of their
results so we can learn about more about
this problem promising avenue.
Okay, and more ideas would be to change
therapy a little bit and concrete idea is
we could actually add problem complexity
estimations into therapy.
What I mean with this is like ask
patients, okay, how much time you spend
ruminating, what typically are the
results of these processes, what are the
costs of these processes.
So we could try to make the costs of the
process more explicit to the patient and
to give them a grasp on how much
opportunity cost they invoke on
themselves by the process.
It's not typically done at the moment but
it could be an idea for improving CBT and
what is also important this is done in
CBT, what I now tell by the way, but it's
really important to keep it in mind.
We learned that a good problem solving
requires an intricate interplay between
the false mode network and brains control
networks.
So it's actually important to have
optimal difficulties for behavioral tasks
given to patients.
If it's too difficult, they will not do
it and if it's too easy, they will not
learn anything from that nor epistemic
value is mindful to say.
And both options are not good for
reducing rumination.
And there's actually another experimental
treatment that shows some success, and
it's called emotional flanker tasks.
And in these tasks, like, patients learn
how to shift their attention away from
bad emotions.
And this could also help stop the
ruminative process, because we learn
that, depending on your mood, you will
have different heuristics in your brain
about what you think about next.
And in the case of bad moods, you don't
have the best heuristics.
So this is another idea for better
treatment.
Yes.
Now I want to talk about a few
limitations and then we can enter the
discussion.
So one limitation is clearly that the
model only discusses typical depression
where behavior breaks down.
However, there are cases of agitated
depression where behavioral output
actually increases or to make it more
abstract, depression is a really
heterogeneous subject and also Rumination
is really heterogeneous.
So we don't have a model actually at the
moment that considers all individual
trajectories.
So this is only a general scheme, so to
say, but it will not fit every
individual.
And the next thing is we describe
plausible ways for Rumination development
but we do not know whether these pathways
play a cause or role in MdD development.
I said briefly that when I have
Rumination at time point T, I will have
more depression at time point T plus
one.
But we do not know whether this is a
causal factor but or only a coincidence
in time, you know what I mean?
So this is also an unsolved problem at
the moment and the last problem which is
also important for active inference lab
nursing in the community is it's not a
mathematical model, it's a conceptual
model that we did and so the next step
would be to make a mathematical model out
of it.
For example, like partially observable
Markov decision process or something like
this in order to be able to simulate it
and to check whether the behavior that we
set it would come out, actually come
out.
So this is another major limitation of
the paper.
Yes, I will skip over that.
I guess we talked about this enough.
So what I want to talk about shortly
before entering the discussion with other
projects that we want to do next with
respect to active inference and what we
actually have done and now under review
at.
Psychological medicine is applying the
active inference framework to
heterogeneous social experiences and
behavior.
And this is actually done in a
mathematical precise way.
So there we have a hierarchical pond or
partially observable Markov decision
process model, and we use it for trying
to explain, like, social withdrawal or
other social problems in depression.
So it's a little bit rumination adjacent
and it's more mathematicized.
A preprint is available, but it's not yet
through the revision process.
And what we also want to do is like,
simulate distorted social functioning and
mental disorders and also to compare
these simulations, or computer
simulations based on active inference to
empirical data, because this is also what
we found in the literature to be
missing.
We have the simulation studies, right,
where we have like these simple games
where active inference computer agents
play like a trust game or something like
that, or where you simulate
hallucinations and psychosis.
And these are really good studies, don't
get me wrong.
But what is missing, in our view, is a
little bit combining these computer
simulations with the behavior of human
being to compare them within one and the
same design.
And this is what we aim to do.
But it's an ambitious project and we are
not finished, so this will take more
work.
And another project that we actually will
finish this year and we have done the
literature screening is we have prepared
like a systematic review of all active
inference literature that is of interest
for psychological treatment.
And this will hopefully at least be a
preprint this year.
So thank you.
These are my coworkers in different
projects to drop a few names.
On the left is Matthias Feldman, then
Lucas Kirchner and Tobias Coupon.
These are the guys that I wrote the
rumination paper with.
Then there's an Elena Ecker.
She's from theoretical cognitive science
groups, and she does a lot of the
computer models for our new projects.
So we need actually scientists that are
better at programming than I am.
And she is doing a lot of the work here.
And then there's Philip Hatzok and Burgut
Kleim.
And with those two people, I also
collaborated on a predictive processing
model of PTSD, which was also published
in Neuroscience and Behavior Reviews at
2020.
Yeah.
So with that, I would like to thank you
for listening and yeah, we can discuss a
few questions if you want now.
Daniel: Awesome.
Max: Thank you.
Daniel: Okay.
All right, well, thanks for the great
presentation.
Looking forward to the discussion.
So, just to sort of begin, how did
predictive processing and active become
integrated with your and your colleagues
research direction?
Were you looking for integrative
frameworks and came across this area, or
did this motivate you to study and enter
into the clinical space?
Max: It's a mixture of two things, I
would say.
One is like observations in patients.
Maybe start with that.
So my friend Tobias Cooper got me
interested in this stuff.
And he had a patient and this patient
really had to struggle with social
phobia.
And what was interesting about him that
he was discarding information that would
challenge his worldview to say right.
So whenever somebody said that he
actually liked him, this one said, oh,
no.
He just pretends to say this because he
wants to be a nice guy.
But in reality, nobody likes me.
And this is what got us interesting,
interested in this line of thinking about
information seeking.
For example, how do organisms seek
information to run their lives?
But also how do organisms discard
information and stay in a depressed or in
an anxious state?
And this is, I guess, one of the reasons
why we started to get interested in
active inference.
And another reason comes from my love or
love from a lot of my colleagues for
simple explanations.
And I don't dean simple as mathematically
simple because I don't get most of the
math, to be honest, fully.
But simple in the sense of we can have
only a few axioms and explain sentient
behavior with it, we can computer
simulate behavior in it and it actually
produces interesting behavior patterns
that we know from the literature.
And this is the other reason why we got
into it.
Daniel: Awesome.
So many directions and ways to go.
But one excerpt from the paper that
jumped out at me was the line between
adaptive problem solving and self
perpetuating maladaptive ruminating.
So how do we know that line and how does
that play out when you're in the clinical
context?
Like what is the appropriate amount of
thinking or overthinking?
How do we really find that line and come
to know it?
Max: Well, there's a short answer that is
we don't know.
So it's hard to say, to be honest, where
the line is because in principle, maybe
you find a good solution if you ruminate
just 2 hours more, right?
You never know.
But we have an answer in the clinical
field in practice and it's like a
pragmaticist answer and it only goes
okay, if you suffer a lot and don't get
your everyday life sorted out, then it
becomes a problem and we have like
measures for that.
So you can assess the global functioning
level of a person and say can he continue
to work, has he friends, has he or she
free time activity that actually fulfill
her?
And this way you can at least say, okay,
has this person a good level of
functioning?
And if not, does rumination impair this
level of functioning?
And yeah, this is a really pragmatic
answer, sorry for that, but this is how
we do it in clinical practice.
Daniel: Totally makes sense also in that
kind of clinical area.
So I was curious, other than rumination,
what other trans diagnostic risk
factors?
What are some examples of those risk
factors and how might they be linked
together in a kind of holistic
understanding?
Or what is the active and non active way
of thinking about the causes and
consequences of these trans diagnostic
risk factors.
Max: One that jumps to mind is emotion
regulation that comes up over and over
again.
So this is a risk factor also for
depression.
It's a risk factor for borderline
personality disorder but it's also a risk
factor for violence.
So a lot of things are connected to poor
emotion regulation and I have to think
shortly to get an active inference answer
out of that.
There's actually a paper, a new one by my
colleague Philip Hatzok about like a
predictive processing model of borderline
personality disorder where he describes
in more detail.
So he is the expert there but maybe we
can just look it up before I make stuff
up that it's not.
Can I just search it shortly and give us
an answer?
Daniel: Sure.
This is internet extended cognitive
rumination yes.
Max: Because I don't feel confident
enough to talk about stuff that was not
my main area of research.
Daniel: Extended rumination you could
make a script or a computer program.
That just iterates.
And whether it experiences that in an
anxious way kind of a second question but
at least from that functional side it's
as if ruminating yes.
Max: So I have the paper here.
Do you see it now?
Daniel: Yes.
Thank you.
Max: Yeah.
So let's see here.
They actually have a model of active
inference terms.
So let's see where it starts.
And it's actually not so simple.
Okay, so what they want to explain is
basically how childhood male treatment
leads to borderline personality
disorder.
And this is important for my
transdiagnostic marker of reduced emotion
regulation because bad emotion regulation
is the symptom of borderline personality
disorder and what they say is, okay,
let's see that.
We have two relevant factors here, strong
negative belief about the self and
others.
It's also typically known for borderline
personality disorder.
So we have high precision to active
inference lab terms here to my prior
belief that other people are bad and I am
also like a loser that cannot do anything
right in his or her life.
And this needs of course if the precision
of the prior is really high, new
information doesn't matter.
And so we have a persistence of effects
of hostility because if the others are
all bad, well, I can be hostile towards
them of fear and of sadness.
And in addition to that, also
contributing to the temporal fluctuations
because we know that borderline is
characterized by sometimes like I really
like my therapist as a borderline
patients and after a while I really hate
him and not a lot in between.
And this may come about due to like a
high uncertainty of beliefs about
consequences of action.
So here about policies.
So here my standard deviation is really
broad and due to that belief updating
regarding policies gets passed.
And this is why I show instability while
at the same time also showing
persistence.
And I show persistence of my worldview
but instability of my behavior.
And this is how they try to explain
borderline personality disorder in active
inference terminology.
But this is only me giving it a try.
I only read the paper once, but this
might be one way how to characterize
like, symptoms of emotion regulation
problems in a conceptual model using
Bayesian terminology.
Daniel: Awesome.
And also in this paper and in yours, it's
on the roadmap towards formalization.
Not like that's the only endpoint, but
going from the empirical evidence and the
ways of thinking and knowing in the
clinician's office through the
integrative frameworks to the pros and to
the graphics that connect different nodes
and edges.
This figure and the ones that you drew,
they're not exactly a Bayes graph, so
it's not exactly ready to be entered into
a computer program.
But it's also not far from a Bayes
graph.
You have variables that could basically
be variables in a Bayes graph.
And so it moves along and brings
collaborators and so on, as in a kind of
methodologically plural way.
There can be development on multiple
fronts and integrate the neuroimaging and
the predispositions and then the
treatment modalities in a way that's not
just like following the causal chain of
the ideology, but rather approaching it
almost like in.
A reverse problem solving way, starting
with the clinician's awareness and view
and first seeking to integrate and
improve the sense making of the clinician
even without a formal model.
Max: Yeah, I would totally agree with
that.
Not much I can say about it.
I think it's totally right what you
said.
There maybe one thing in clinical
experience, at least in psychology, I
don't dare to speak of other fields, but
their backward translation is really
important.
So this is what you described, right?
So going back from the clinical
phenomenon to more precise view, for
example, in formal modeling and typically
problems got tackled the other way
around.
And this oftentimes doesn't work as well
as backwards translation because
typically problems got thought through by
basic scientists that are really good at
doing this formal modeling but don't
model necessarily the right parameters
from our view at least, because they lack
the clinical experience.
And so both parties working together is
really important.
Like guys like us bring in the important
parameters, or at least where we think
they could be important from clinical
practice and the more mathematically
inclined can model them.
And so there could be a fruitful
collaboration between so start with
backward translation, then do forward
translation, then do another loop of
backward translation.
And I guess this is a fruitful way of
advancing psychiatry and psychology.
Daniel: Wow.
So, a related question.
To what extent, either today or in the
future do you think patients would be
clued in to some of this lexicon and
ontology?
For example, is it enough to just say,
hey, here's the new recommendation,
here's the new exercise plan?
Or is it explicitly oriented around
communicating within these ways of
talking about belief, uncertainty,
information and so on?
Max: I think it can be done with
patients, and it should be done to a
certain extent.
I think it's not plausible to teach them
all the math and stuff like this will not
be possible for at least a lot of them,
for sure.
If you have a mathematics professor
patience, it would be easy for him or
her, but in most cases, no, not that.
But you could talk about precision, you
could talk about surprising, you could
talk about hierarchical learning, and I
guess it's important to do this.
You could simplify models into like,
vicious circles.
One could easily draw a simple vicious
circle with the help of our remnant model
and teach them or the patients a few
Bayesian adjacent words, at least, to
better understand their condition.
And I think this is important because
psycho education actually is proven to
help, right?
The more you know about the condition,
the higher your chances of getting better
are in a lot of cases.
And so I guess, yes, you could teach them
at least base rules and a few simple
things, not doing a lot of math, but
like, drawing a few graphs and try to
teach them the basics would be a good
idea because I guess everybody can get
what precise information is and what
belief updating, how it functions.
In principle, this is teachable to most
of us.
Daniel: Yeah, one example that from the
talk you mentioned, like, with the loss
of an important person in our life, our
social or our emotional support policies
are going to have to be updated.
If there was some source we went to for
information and that source no longer
became available, we would have to change
our epistemic foraging.
And of course, this exists in the social
space.
And so when life changes, when our
generative model or when our generative
process, our niche changes, we should
expect the unexpected.
It's a totally normal, surprising, but
expected surprise event that opens up the
discussion to like, there will be beliefs
that will be changing, there will be new
policies or policies that you didn't
previously take.
Maybe now is the time to try them out.
And there's going to be volatility as
you're learning the consequences of
action.
So stick with it and try something three
times before saying that it doesn't
work.
Even without appeal to mathematics,
that's very powerful.
And I think the way that somebody might
say, well, in this double blind study,
these two groups, this treatment that
we're going to go with, it's been shown
that in this context, these two groups,
this group did better.
And no one says, well, slow down.
The Ttest used a lot of mathematics.
I'm not a statistics professor.
So people accept the epistemology of the
group differential statistics and of
diagnostic statistics, even though one
could do 100 PhDs in theoretical
statistics and in computational
statistics.
And so it just speaks, I think, to the
early stage when the field is even
perceived as being math heavy because
we're in such a methodological
developmental stage.
But there will be layers and ways of
working that will not mention any more
technical detail than someone just saying
the double blind study has provided
evidence for X.
Max: Yes, I can say two things about it.
The one thing is a philosophical thing
Daniel Dennett talked about free floating
rationales, right?
So a free floating rationale, in case you
don't know, is like when lions go for
givels.
It's an example that he likes to give.
The gazelles do these showboating types
of jumps and the lions typically don't go
after the gazelle that can show this
behavior, but go after the injured ones
that cannot do this anymore.
Right.
But we can be quite certain that neither
the lion nor the gazelle knows what they
are doing, but it works without
knowledge.
And this is what he calls a free floating
rationale.
There is a rationale behind the behavior
of the lion, but he doesn't need to know
it in order to take advantage of it.
And this is the case for science and this
is also the case for patients.
You don't need to know every detail of a
mathematical formalism in order to grasp
some of the concepts and to advance your
understanding of the world using these
concepts.
But of course it helps, but for patients
it's the same, and for us it's the same.
And I think free floating rationales are
a really important concept to describe.
Why a lot of the times you don't need to
know the exact formalisms.
And another idea that I want to give is
more like science, of making niche
constructions more applicable to the
mainstream.
And this is well, at the beginning it's
hard because you need to program every
little bit yourself.
There are no toolboxes, nothing to help
you.
Not really books, just a few experts.
But after a while books come out.
After a while you get toolboxes that
actually simplify a lot of the process.
You don't need to write the helper
functions yourself.
You can use the toolbox in a lot of cases
and so after a while it becomes more
widely applicable in science and maybe at
someday, I don't know, Spss or something,
one of these statistics software, maybe
not SPF, has like a way to click through
active inference algorithms.
That's it.
But then in principle everybody can use
it.
Then you have new problems because people
will use it without actually
understanding it.
But I would predict that it gets simpler
and simpler to use.
And I would say overall this is a good
thing because this allows a lot more
scientists to jump in on the endeavor.
Daniel: Thanks.
Yeah.
Great points.
One of your quotes, the short one, was
Existence precedes essence.
And it reminded me of a 2015 paper of
Friston and mathis which is entitled I Am
Therefore I Think.
And that of course is a little bit of an
inversion on I think therefore I am,
which puts rumination before the horse or
the cart before the horse.
I'm not exactly sure, but I think
therefore I am.
It actually puts thinking and ruminating
first.
Whereas this existentialist quote that
you provided concords well, with certain
ways of thinking about reflexive systems
in active inference.
So what did you mean with the
introduction of that quote?
And how does that existentialist angle
play out in the clinical setting?
Max: Yeah, these are maybe two questions
disguised as one.
I start with the existentialist worldview
in clinical settings.
Well, I think it's important for clinical
science and more so for clinical practice
because we need to believe in a certain
type of liberty in order to help
patients.
If we believe everything is predetermined
by, I don't know, brain chemistry, even
if it's true, this will make changing
your behavior hard because you can always
say, well, I cannot change my behavior.
It's all in my, I don't know, genes or
what type of biological reductionism you
like.
So I guess we need these existentialist
idea that you yourself are in control of
your life in order to make therapy work.
Right?
So we need to at least have a compatible
hard English word like this.
Even if determinism is true, we need to
have it combined with some sort of
liberty or belief in liberty.
And I guess this is where active
inference jumps in, because active
inference allows a formal description
about self control.
And then we have a definition of acting
in the world and learning new things that
doesn't require, like, fairy tales.
And it's compatible with determinism.
And with this worldview, you have a
worldview that on one hand is compatible
with determinism and on the other hand
allows for a concept like self control,
agency policy, learning all the things.
And so it can also be used for
psychotherapy.
Daniel: Interesting.
Max: I hope this answers the question,
but this is what I can say.
Daniel: Yeah, there's so much depth,
obviously many threads and traditions in
the clinical setting and that full stack
from the manifest behavioral on through
the cognitive and psychological, but
verging or anchored in or descended from
the metaphysical, that's a full spectrum
area that seems like it must be navigated
in the clinician's education.
But even in like the 1 hour that you're
spending with somebody, I imagine that it
could probably oscillate a lot in where
you're focusing from.
Here's how to tie your shoe to here's why
things matter.
Abstractly.
Max: There's more philosophy, especially
practical philosophy for therapy, than
one would think because patients bring it
up all the time.
Right?
I mean, one of the problems of depression
is if it's going to be really severe, is
this, for example, nihilism kicks in so
nothing makes sense anymore.
And then, as you said, why should
anything matter at all?
Then becomes an interesting question and
a pressing question for them.
Daniel: What's your go to response?
Why does anything matter?
Max: It's a hard question I would try to
get do you always thought that nothing
matters?
What was different when something
mattered for you?
How was your life then and what changed
why you came to these conclusions now and
how do you feel when you think about your
old worldview versus new worldview?
So I would try to challenge their
worldview by their own worldview a few
years ago.
This is not always working because you
have patients that have actually gone
through a lot of difficult times in their
lives but typically like their work view
was not always depressed.
Daniel: Yes, that seems to do multiple
things.
By responding to a question with a
question it puts an active posture back
into the conversation.
So at the very least policies can be
selected that aren't rumination and
consequences could be learned.
Even if there's going to be a higher low
precision on that learning at least it
opens the door to movements.
Whereas just well person X said this or
that, that response may land or inspire
or not but it reifies the Pacification
and therefore may not kind of like an
inactive layer promote the movement.
Max: Yeah, I just wanted to say awesome
things the same and if you try something
like person XY that says this is the
reason why your life works, this will in
most cases not work at all.
They will say something like but this
person doesn't go through that many
hardships that I did what is oftentimes
true or something like that.
Right?
So often it's better if the ideas are
sampled from their own generative models
from a lost part of the distribution, so
to say, and not from outside.
Typically you have to try to get them to
think out of their own worldview and not
of your work view or someone else's
worldview with the seldom functions.
Daniel: So another interesting area you
mentioned the problem difficulty,
complexity, time uncertainty
estimations.
So kind of like a cognitive task analysis
in the CBT setting where different tasks
are estimated again along these axes of
how challenging is that for you or how
complex does that task seem to you, how
does that really play out?
Because it really seems like something in
the email inbox or in writing a paper
with some improved signposting or
learning even around which tasks are
hard, which tasks are clear, which tasks
are threatening our well being, those
kinds of metadata on policy selection and
being able to see that could help us
select better policy and not to change
our preferences.
Which is how sometimes behavior change is
approached by changing what people are
supposed to want, but by bringing this
kind of cybernetic clarity around action
selection to support people in different
contexts, making the decisions that can
then credibly be said to be more in
alignment with what they do want.
Max: Yeah, what is typically already been
done is to let patients guess how high
they would rate the probability of
succeeding right.
So when we do this behavioral therapy,
they are typically asked, okay, what do
you think?
How probable is that?
You're going to go there until next
week?
And it's a rule of thumb by clinicians
that has no Bayesian science, but we say
if it's 80% or higher probability, one
should aim for it.
If it's lower, it's too difficult.
But if it's trivial, if it's 99.9%
probability, it's also not worth
typically pursuing, at least not always.
But I guess the problem with that is that
I don't know a solution for this is my
subjective probability, right.
How I think, how probable it is, I don't
have a good grasp in all cases on how
difficult it really is for me because
there are all sorts of biases that would
keep me from making such assumptions.
I don't have a solution for that.
But what would be good is to have more
variables that we could estimate in order
to actually have more information on how
difficult a task is.
But for most cases we haven't.
And when we have them, we know that what
patients think, how difficult it is and
how difficult it really is hasn't the
best correlation.
Sure, it's positively correlated, but how
good I think my short term memory, for
example, is and how good it really is is
not the same.
And this is hard to solve problems for
clinical science.
I have to think about it longer, but it
would.
Giving patients tool to actually improve
their probability estimates would be
great.
But I guess it's also hard to do due to
all these things that you said before.
Right.
If the problem is complex, multi layered,
and has a lot of variation and good luck
actually finding a way to estimating
probabilities, but we could start for
simple problems and maybe this helps
patients, but I have to think about it
more.
To be honest, it's not easy to find
better solutions there.
Daniel: Yeah.
Even just on paper or digitally
journaling, but then eventually
potentially integrating with the kinds of
formal models we've been discussing, it
can be really nice to know, hey, there's
a lot of stuff that you said had a below
50 chance of happening and nine out of
ten times you've done that.
So maybe next time you're in the zone of
uncertainty, just go for it.
You tend to systematically overestimate
your confidence in this or you
overestimate how much other people will
appreciate this kind of consequence.
And maybe writing three thank you notes a
day would be a great use of 20 minutes.
Max: Yeah, these are all really good
ideas and this is also things that are
done right.
What is missing, but what is doable in
principle is tracking certain behavior.
Like an easy example would be aggressive
behavior.
For example, counting how much verbal
aggression was shown or physical
aggression was shown over the days.
And then look what the expectation of the
patient was.
And comparing those two and there you
could do like patient belief updating in
a simplified form.
Yeah, this would be a great idea.
It's always then possible I would say
when the behavior is clear enough and
easy enough to count right.
As soon as if it's getting more unclear
this will not work but it could work for
a lot of problem behaviors like self
harm, aggression, lying in bed, like in
depression, something like that.
Daniel: So it makes me think about that
contrast that you provided between reward
oriented frameworks which struggle to
describe rumination as it's not in the
short or medium or long term necessarily
oriented with rewards.
So the only explanation becomes well,
something is off in the reward function
which is kind of tautological.
And so that's a little bit of a local and
a constrained explanation.
Whereas when we see policy selection
external overt movement in the world as
well as internal COVID policy selection
like attention and mental action when we
see those actions as being oriented
around reduction of free energy which is
bounding surprise and therefore, based
upon what is likely, not what is
necessarily the most rewarding.
It opens up that view to, again say, how
many of this behavior do you expect to
happen in the next week?
Yes, in a dream world we would aim for
zero of event of this number.
We'll aim for you to be full time
employed by next week.
That sounds awesome but what do we
honestly expect in 12345 weeks?
And then we're going to actually be
looking back in and then instead of maybe
feeling like well you're going to leave
the port and then you're going to have to
sail across an ocean it can be more like
there are checkpoints.
We're looking back at the buoys that we
passed.
We have the next three buoys that we're
looking towards.
We can do smaller corrections and there
will be volatility so there's going to
continue to be surprised.
We're not going to exactly hit every
milestone per se but if we are on this
trajectory we're going to be moving
essentially as much as we possibly could
in the right direction and spending less
time just hypothesizing about like a
total counterfactual world where the
issue is already resolved.
Max: Yes and this is a metaphor that is
also used in therapy quite often, right.
The one of the mountain climber.
And the mountain climber typically needs
a guide if he's a newbie.
And what psychotherapy can do is provide
a good way over the mountain, so to say,
provide a good place for resting, doing
the next step, doing the next step, doing
the next step.
And, yeah, this is really resonating with
what you said.
Namely, we have to take a big problem and
cut it into little problems that we can
solve one after another, so it becomes
plausible to actually solve it.
Yes, I would totally agree and
emotional.
Daniel: Flanker tasks, I'm not exactly
sure what those would be.
But it just made me think of our policy
selection throughout the day and all of
the fires we have to put out or all of
the bubbling soups that we have to tend
to with thirst and rest and breathing and
physical exercise and all of these
different aspects to our cognitive and
emotional well being.
It's like there's many things to attend
to which is why our attention is so
variable as a feature, it's not a bug.
So the fact that we have exactly
pathological or not just neurodiverse
states that involve a fixation of
attention and also the inability to
fixate attention, it just starts with our
experience of the day and of our
attention to our body and our
surroundings and to the bigger questions
that we know impinge on us.
But also we can't necessarily have the
geopolitics and the climate change solved
just by thinking about it but we also
don't want to neglect what are important
issues and then seeing strategies and
having the discussion about strategies
and tactics in that attentional space
instead of in the reward space.
Not to bash or anything like that, but
that conversation is about well, what
should we value more or less and then why
are these values translating effectively
or not into behavior?
Whereas the attention and surprise angle
is like being more in the game and your
local view instead of watching the game
and just saying, well, I want this to be
the outcome.
Max: Exactly, yeah, I want to say a
little bit about this attention focus and
attention spreading that you mentioned.
I almost said it in the talk but I say it
now.
Like for example, ADHD is not necessarily
like disorder in the sense that it's a
dysfunction, right?
So it can also be described or maybe
better described as a neurodivergent
property of some human beings so they
shift attention more easily and this is
depending on the environment, a good
thing because if you stuck your attention
at one place too much well, you might not
notice what is going around in your
surroundings.
So you have to be able to focus away from
certain points of attention.
And you want to have, in a group,
individuals that have really sticky
attention so they can focus on a task
really good.
But you also want to have the other ones
that have really floating attention spans
in order to see new opportunities or see
danger.
And so I think this can be really easily
explained by evolutionary theory, right?
So we have variance over the population
and this variance is not a bug, it's a
feature.
And on the more extreme ends of the
variance you find phenotypes that are
problematic from time to time but
depending on the surroundings, always
depending on the surroundings, right?
So on the one hand you might have
something like OCD like behavior and on
the other hand something like more ADHD
like behavior and it can even jump
between the two.
Interestingly, but this is not
necessarily always bad.
It really depends on your environment.
And that humans differ with respect to
this parameters is also not a bug, but a
feature of evolution, I would say, and
also a feature of our learning history.
Of course.
Daniel: Totally agreed.
For individual and collective behavioral
strategies, they're often discussed as if
they were context independence when there
are ant colony foraging strategies that
work in the desert and they work not as
well in the jungle.
So just like it is with our attention,
there's attention surroundings that
support this kind of work, but not that
kind of work or well being.
So being able to talk about the
generative model and the generative
process and their engagements in a rich
way, I guess it's what brings us
together.
But it's also what feels like a powerful
place to regather and remember a lot of
the important qualitative threads and
empirical threads in this important
clinical area and also move forward in a
way that's not just adding like another
measurement onto the pile.
Because a lot of these models, as you
continue to develop their formality and
ambiguity to integrate data, they will
provide a new view on previous findings
and patterns that may have been taken in
the Ttest reward learning world to be
conclusive, or this or that will be shown
to be just two darts thrown into a huge
neurodiversity space.
And there might be other studies or sets
of studies where what was treated as
being all over the place are now
perfectly in line and tell a really
coherent story about, for example, how
strong negative beliefs about the self
and others or high uncertainty of beliefs
about the consequences of action end up
helping us just do what we do.
Max: Yes, totally agree.
Maybe it's interesting there's even
reconceptualization going on, like
thinking about psychopathology in more
like evolutionary terms, like Stefan
Hoffman, for example, and Stephen Hayes.
Stephen Hayes is known as the founding
father of Acts.
So acceptance and commitment based
therapy.
And those two guys have a new therapy
idea where we describe psychopathology on
a pragmatic basis.
So we define psychopathology as behavior
that doesn't fit any more the current
circumstances.
So there you have the context and right.
And I think it's clever to do it more
that way because, for example, PTSD like
behavior, well, if you're a soldier in a
really bad region of the world, this is
not psychopathology.
This is allowing you to survive.
The problem is of PTSD, that the war
comes home with you or dramatically bend
comes home with you, and now your
behavior doesn't fit the environment
anymore.
Right.
And I think this is a neat way of
describing a lot of psychopathology as
maladaptive behavior in the evolutionary
sense.
And typically it was adaptive in the
past.
Like, also, what this, like, borderline
personality disorder slide that I have on
the screen right now is the same because
it was adaptive in the past to behave
like this in some circumstances, in a
bare childhood, so to say, but it's not
anymore, but it's continued despite being
ineffective.
And I guess this is a good definition for
a lot of psychopathology.
Not for all, I would say.
For example, there is really
psychopathology where you have broken
inference, so to say, and not just for
example in psychosis.
In some cases I would say yes, you have
more like brain pathology, you have more
really broken inference, and the rules of
active inference don't work anymore, so
to say.
But I don't think that the rules.
Active inference lab don't work in
rumination.
They work perfectly fine, but the
organism has placed himself in a
situation where they don't learn anything
new by applying the same rules that
everybody else applies.
So it's broken models, not broken
inference.
And I guess this is true for a lot of
psychopathology.
Daniel: So what are your next moves with
this line of research?
You mentioned some of the papers.
What would you like those papers to
show?
Or who would you like them to speak to?
And show what?
Max: Maybe I start with the literature
review that we are planning.
I would like to get to know what the
literature, so to say, says about active
inference informed treatments.
This is what I would like to find out.
I don't have a lot of hypotheses.
I want to screen the literature and find
out whether we can synthesize them into
an active inference informed model of
what is psychotherapy doing.
And I would like to speak this model to a
clinical audience in the first place.
Again, so I want the clinical population
to learn more about active inference.
I know that psychiatrists sometimes know
about active inference literature, but
psychologists, at least not clinical
psychologists, typically don't know a lot
about it.
And I would like to change this a little
bit at least.
And afterwards the next logical step
would be to implement some of the insight
into actual therapy programs.
But this is something for more of the
future.
But it would be interesting whether you
can really have something like an active
inference informed therapy, but now we
are talking more like five to ten years.
Daniel: Awesome.
Do you have any final thoughts or
questions?
And then I will close with a short quote
to fire back.
Max: Yes, you are.
No, I don't have any final remarks or
questions.
I would like to thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak and now I want
to resolve my uncertainty regarding the
quote.
Great.
Daniel: The quote is from Henry David
Thoreau and it's drawing a connection
between the paths that we ruminate on,
that we walk upon and travel upon, and
then the paths in the mind.
So I thought it was Africa, so throw a
rope.
I had not lived there a week before.
My feet wore a path from my door to the
pond side and though it is five or six
years since I trot it.
It is still quite distinct.
It is true, I fear, that others may have
fallen into it and so helped to keep it
open.
The surface of the earth is soft and
impressive by the feet of men.
And so with the paths which the mind
travels how worn and dusty then must be
the highways of the world.
How deep the ruts of tradition and
conformity.
Max: Thank you.
Awesome.
And thank you for having me.
Daniel: Till next time.
Thanks a lot.
Max: See you.
Bye.